hallo zusammen schön guten Tag wir sind
live mit ZDF heute live in den letzten
Monaten konnten sich die Menschen in der
ukrainischen Hauptstadt Kiew
einigermaßen sicher fühlen das Leben
lief einigermaß normal ab wenn man das
so bezeichnen kann das ist seit heute
morgen wieder anders russland hat Kiew
und weitere ukrainische Städte mit
Luftangriffen überzogen passiert ist das
heute morgen die meisten Menschen waren
gerade auf dem Weg zur Arbeit es gibt
Tote und Verletzte wir schauen uns das
kurz auf der Karte an
die russischen Raketen gingen nicht nur
auf Städte nahe der Kampfgebiete nieder
sondern vor allem auf Städte in denen es
bisher meist friedlich blieb zum
Beispiel im Westen etwa Lemberg und auch
eben wie gesagt in der Hauptstadt Kiew
deshalb wurden etliche Zivilisten am
Morgen von diesen Attacken überrascht
ja über die jüngsten Bombardements
wollen wir heute reden und zwar mit der
Vorsitzenden des
Verteidigungsausschusses im Bundestag
hat Zimmermann von der SPD wir haben dem
Militärexperten Markus Kolb und man
sieht sie schon mit unserer Reporterin
Alisa jung sie hat die Luftangriffe
heute morgen in Kiew erlebt vielleicht
noch ganz kurz vorab alle beantworten
gerne Ihre und eure Fragen am besten in
die Chats schreiben oder eben per Mail
schicken jetzt aber zu dir Alissa hallo
wir sind froh dass wir dich heute
erreichen
hallo schönen schönen schönes hallo zu
euch nach Deutschland wenn man das heute
so sagen kann natürlich du fehlst
aktuell auf der Straße wir sehen dich
das heißt die Luftangriffe sind jetzt
erstmal bis auf weiteres vorbei
das ist nicht so ganz klar also es gab
schon auch wieder ein Hinweis immer
wieder im Verlauf des Tages auch in die
Bunker zu gehen wo wir ja auch den
Vormittag verbracht haben wir sind
ungefähr seit 12 13 Uhr Ortszeit wieder
auf der Straße unterwegs und es ist
natürlich hier allen nicht ganz klar
wann könnte ein nächster Angriff kommen
denn auch heute morgen die Angriffe das
war das mehr was es hier so schwierig
gemacht hat es war nicht ganz eindeutig
welche Ziele sollten die denn treffen
denn was das was passiert ist ist das
Zivilisten das zivile Ziele getroffen
worden sind und ich stehe jetzt hier
mitten im Zentrum vor dem jackchenko
Park und der Universität und in diesem
Park ist ein Kinderspielplatz und eben
hinter uns das Gebäude in der
Universität und das war eines der Ziele
also einfach hier mittendrin in ein
Wohngebiet und das hat die Menschen hier
und uns eben auch um kurz nach acht
geweckt am Morgen überrascht und wie ihr
auch schon berichtet habt gab es auch
leider dabei Tote und Verletzte
genau auf diesen Punkt würde ich gerne
ein bisschen näher eingehen wie hast du
ganz persönlich mit deinem Team heute
morgen die Raketenangriffe erlebt
wir waren alle noch in unseren Zimmern
im Hotel kurz davor loszugehen auch und
in unseren Tag zu starten und zu drehen
und dann gab es eine sehr sehr laute
Explosion mehrere Explosionen ganz in
der Nähe leider auch unmittelbar vor
unserem Hotel übrigens der kracht den
ihr jetzt gerade hört das nur mal kurz
um das auch aufzuklären ist weil die
Menschen hier schon wieder aufräumen
hier sind die Fenster kaputt gegangen
und die Türen teilweise kaputt gegangen
und hier wird gerade gesägt neben mir
denn sie räumen schon wieder auf das ist
auch bemerkenswert denn die Angriffe
sind ja erst wenige Stunden her und wenn
das gleich wieder ein bisschen ruhiger
wird nutze ich natürlich auch die Zeit
aber vielleicht könnt ihr erstmal selber
sehen warum es gerade hier so laut ist
ihr seht also hier
unmittelbar einen Bezirk in der
Innenstadt und seht auch auf dem Boden
die Scherben denn es hat hier eben
einige Gläser rausgehauen einige Fenster
sind dabei kaputt gegangen und jetzt
versuchen die Ukrainerinnen Ukraine hier
schon wieder so gut wie möglich
aufzuräumen so und jetzt könnte ich euch
auch noch mal erzählen von heute morgen
also wie es uns dann ergangen ist wir
haben es wird jetzt beim wahrscheinlich
ein bisschen so laut bleiben aber
wahrscheinlich oder hoffentlich
funktioniert das trotzdem wir haben also
die lauten Explosionen gehört und dann
sind wir natürlich ganz schnell runter
in unseren Schutzbunker gegangen das war
auch was der Bürgermeister was Klitschko
angeordnet hat oder den Menschen
empfohlen hat Schutz zu suchen das haben
auch wir getan und haben dann eben
mehrere Stunden im Bunker verbracht und
jetzt so ruhig in Anführungszeichen wie
es jetzt gerade ist ist es ungefähr seit
12 13 Uhr Ortszeit
das sind Schilderungen die unter die
Haut gehen vielleicht nutzen wir die
Zeit auch während gesägt wird und
schauen noch mal in den Beitrag von Nina
kurschhelden rein sie hat die Bilder
heute morgen
zusammengetragen und hier kommt ihr
weiter
es ist 8 Uhr heute früh in Kief die BBC
spricht live mit ihrem Korrespondenten
Ugo batschiger in kiel-einschlag
das Zentrum der ukrainischen Hauptstadt
wird hart getroffen Bürgermeister
klitschko hat die Menschen aufgerufen
sich in Sicherheit zu bringen es sei
Zitat kritische Infrastruktur getroffen
worden viele werden verletzt unklar ist
noch wie viele Tote es gibt die Menschen
in den Städten waren auf dem Weg zur
Arbeit als die Raketen einschlugen
die Angriffe kamen für sie völlig
unerwartet
ich wollte zur Arbeit plötzlich die
Explosionen wir sind gesund aber die
Menschen die zur falschen Zeit am
falschen Ort waren sie sind jetzt
verletzt oder tot
nicht nur Kiew ist Ziel der Angriffe
auch in anderen Städten wie hier nie pro
gibt es Raketenbeschuss
Präsident selensky meldet sich am
Vormittag per Video
sie wollen Panik und Chaos erzeugen sie
wollen unser Energiesystem zerstören sie
sind hoffnungslos das zweite Ziel sind
Menschen aber denkt immer daran die
Ukraine existierte bevor dieser Feind
auftauchte und die Ukraine wird auch
danach existieren
russlands Präsident Putin rechtfertigt
die Angriffe als Vergeltung für den
Anschlag auf die Brücke zur Krim
wenn die terroristischen Anschläge auf
unser Land weitergehen wird Russland
hart reagieren daran sollte niemand
zweifeln
in Kiew herrscht Blanca Angst wer kann
bringt sich in Sicherheit Bunker aber
auch U-Bahn-Stationen sind überfüllt
wir versuchen das Gespräch trotzdem
weiterzuführen du hast einige Zeit schon
im Wohnhaus verbracht die eben auch
viele andere Menschen die hast du die
Menschen erlebt was mache ich mit dir
von Antifa
das macht vor allem und das habt Ihr ja
eben gerade gesehen dass sie sich nicht
unterkriegen lassen wollen dass sie
natürlich trotzdem hier meinte
weitermachen wollen dass Sie bereits
schon aufräumen damit es auch gerade
unseren Ort mal kurz geändert dass ihr
sehen könnt wo das hier wirklich auch
stattfand ihr seht also hier den
Kinderspielplatz und direkt vor dem
Kinderspielplatz ist ein riesengroßer
Krater also hier wurde mitten ins
Zentrum auf Zivilisten ein Angriff
verübt und das hat natürlich viele hier
wahnsinnig geschockt denn mehrere Monate
war das jetzt ruhig hier in Kiew
vermeintlich oder ein verhältnismäßig
ruhig sagen wir es mal so es gab
zumindest also Angriffe in dieser Art
jetzt schon seit mehreren Monaten nicht
mehr und das hat natürlich viele
geschockt und wir haben auch mit vielen
Menschen hier heute schon gesprochen die
gesagt haben dass erinnert sie alles 24
februar an den Beginn des Krieges als
eben auch die Hauptstadt Ziel solcher
Angriffe war und das hat natürlich jetzt
all diese Erinnerungen wieder hoch
geholt und viele ganz wahnsinnig
natürlich auch erschreckt und wir waren
eben gerade auch in dem Haus hier direkt
neben uns bei einer Familie wo die
Scheiben aus den Fenstern geflogen sind
und sie sagen auch sie verstehen das
nicht warum wurde hier ein Angriff auf
Zivilisten verübt das war kein
militärisches Ziel sondern es ist
Zivilisten die das hier getroffen hat
auf ihrem Weg zur Arbeit zur Uni und ihr
könnt es ja eben sehen Mitten neben
einem Kinderspielplatz und das macht
natürlich hier viele schon auch
fassungslos und gleichzeitig eben wollen
sie Widerstandskraft und trotzig hier
einfach zeigen sie lassen sich nicht
unterkriegen und räumen hier sogar schon
wieder auf
und das widerspricht natürlich auch der
Darstellung von russlands Präsident
Putin der gesagt hat er hätte vor allem
energieinfrastrukturelle Objekte treffen
wollen mit diesem Anschlägen Angriffen
mag hat gefragt ob sich die
Ukrainerinnen und Ukrainer überhaupt
noch von diesen Terrorangriffen
einschüchtern lassen so nennt er sie
oder ob sie nicht eher deren
Entschlossenheit Stärken diese Fahrgasse
gerade beantwortet Heinz fragt noch auf
youtube ist es wahr dass die deutsche
Botschaft getroffen wurde
nein das ist nicht korrekt also wir
haben tatsächlich sogar auch in unserem
Bunker weil wir unmittelbar zur
deutschen Botschaft im Moment
untergebracht sind mit Mitarbeiterinnen
und Mitarbeitern der Botschaft
zusammengesessen und verbracht also das
ist nicht korrekt das fand aber ganz in
der Nähe der deutschen Botschaften weil
ja auch mitten im Zentrum ist statt und
deswegen ist es nicht richtig dass die
deutsche Botschaft getroffen wurde
sondern es ist einfach sie ist die
befindet sich auch einfach im Zentrum
hier in Kiew ganz auch hier in der Nähe
von diesem park-chef chemco Park und
auch der Universität wo wir uns gerade
befinden Elisa letzte Frage an dich wie
bereitet ihr euch auf die Nacht auf die
nächsten Tage vor
das ist sehr schwierig sich hier
irgendwie vorbereiten zu können denn
dieser Angriff war ja so die Fuß so die
fuse Ziele das ist uns schwer fällt und
auch allen Menschen hier sich da
entsprechend darauf vorzubereiten wir
sind natürlich wachsam vor allem
natürlich auch bei jedem Geräusch das
merkt man schon hier auch auf der Straße
viele zucken zusammen wenn ein lautes
Geräusch dann da ist und deswegen wir
bleiben wachsam wir sind vorsichtig wir
passen auf uns auf und das machen auch
alle Menschen hier in der Ukraine die
das natürlich leider schon diesen
schrecklichen Angriffskrieg auf ihr Land
seit Monaten gewohnt sind und dann
natürlich auch inzwischen auch fast
eingeübt sind ein wenig für solche
schrecklichen Situationen wie sie sich
da am besten verhalten müssen
und dann möchte ich dir noch einen
Kommentar von Peter Rettig auf Youtube
Vorlesen er schreibt Dank an Alisa für
ihren Einsatz diesen Dank möchten wir
uns gerne anschließen dir und deinem
Team alles Gute euch tschüss
danke tschüss
ja soweit die jüngsten Eindrücke live
aus der Hauptstadt Kiew wir lassen uns
diese Angriffe nun vom Militärexperten
Markus Kolb einschätzen guten Tag hallo
russlands Präsident Putin sagt dass sein
vergeltungsanschläge für die Angriffe
auf der Krim wie sehr hat dieser Angriff
sein Regime getroffen
ja so zunächst mal dieser Begriff
vergeltungsanschlag ist bereits ein
russisches Propaganda narrativ also man
musste sehr vorsichtig sein diese
Begriffe in den westlichen Medien zu
replizieren was wir hier sehen in Kiel
und den anderen ukrainischen Städten ist
ein weiterer Terrorangriff in der langen
langen Reihe russischer Kriegsverbrechen
ich betone an der Stelle immer das
Artikel 22 und 23 der Haager
Landkreisordnung von 1907 explizit
verbieten dass die zivile Infrastruktur
beschossen wird diese Hagel
antriebsordnung ist im übrigen vom
russischen Zaren ratifiziert worden wie
auch von den ganzen anderen damaligen
Nationen also sprich völkerrechtlich ist
die Lage eindeutig es handelt sich hier
nicht um Vergeltungsangriffe es handelt
sich hier um Terrorakte gegenüber der
Zivilbevölkerung und wenn dieser Krieg
vorbei ist dann wird man sich am
Strafgerichtshof in Den Haag eingängig
mit diesen russischen Aktionen befassen
müssen wenn sie jetzt fragen was heißt
das für das russische Regime putin ist
derzeit stark unter Druck von der ul
nationalistischen Seite Russlands die
ihm vorwirft ob sie das jetzt glauben
oder nicht er sei zu weich oder zu lieb
er würde den Krieg er sozusagen nicht
mit voller Härte führen und dieses
ultra-nationalistische Milieu beginnt so
seit etwa einer Woche ganz offen Putin
übrigens auch schon gut und verschiedene
russische Generäle unter anderem auch
gerade mal auf den Generalstabschef sehr
offen zu kritisieren das heißt Putin
steht unter einem gewissen
innenpolitischen Druck und ich kann mir
vorstellen dass er jetzt einfach
versucht durch solche Aktionen dieses
Milieu etwas zu beruhigen oder sich als
starken Mann darzustellen das macht
militärisch natürlich keinen Sinn es ist
für mich eher ein Zeichen zunehmender
Ratlosigkeit
also diese Bezeichnung Vergeltungsschlag
Propaganda war wohl eher dann ein
Vorwand denn so eine große angelegte
Angriffsaktion lässt sich ja auch nur
schwer innerhalb so kurzer Zeit
realisieren
nein das würde ich nicht sagen also die
die Abschüsse soweit ich sie mir
angeschaut habe die kommen von weit
innerhalb des russischen Mutterlandes
also man vermutet im Moment astrakan und
ebenso von sägeschütz sägestützten
Körpern also U-Booten und Schiffen im
Schwarzen Meer das sind also
Installationen die ständig bewaffnet
sind also zum Beispiel ich kann da oder
touchka Batterien die auch relativ
schnell schießen können also es ist
jetzt nicht so dass man wochenlang so
eine Aktion vorbereiten müsste sondern
man kann das schon aus dem Stand machen
die Frage ist natürlich aus welchen
Gründen also militärisch hat es keinen
Wert im Gegenteil militärisch ist das
sogar recht dumm weil diese diese
Messers die sind recht teuer
und die russische Rüstungsindustrie hat
nur einen begrenzten Bestand davon und
wenn sie jetzt schauen was richtet dass
bei der ukrainischen Zivilbevölkerung an
wir haben es ja gesehen bei ihrer
korrespondantin genau das Gegenteil von
dem was putin will es macht die Leute
nur noch entschlossener und nur noch
härter in ihrem Widerstand
wir haben eine Frage auf Youtube
von Chaos Fraktal ist mit dem neuen
general Putins mit weiteren
Raketenangriffen zu rechnen
ja Simon wahrscheinlich so rowiki der
jetzt ernannt worden ist also nach
russischen Quellen zum zum gesamt
Oberbefehlshaber für alle armeegruppen
in der Ukraine ich glaube dass ehrlich
gesagt nicht zu rohrvicin ist ein
weiteres Beispiel in einer Reihe sehr
brutaler russischer Generäle die die
schon so erzogen wurden in der
Sowjetunion die auch alle in Syrien
waren also Alexander lapin während
anderes Beispiel oder dorninghoff der im
Mai abgesetzt wurde außer Brutalität
haben diese Generäle eigentlich nichts
zu bieten sie haben insbesondere nicht
die flexible feine Operationsführung die
wir zum Beispiel in der Raki Vision
Operation im September gesehen haben ich
denke der Krieg wird in dieser Hinsicht
ja nach der alten sowjetischen Maxime
weitergehen größtmögliche Brutalität
alles kaputt schießen
wenn wir uns jetzt so Hobbyking selbst
anschauen der war ich glaube seit Juli
verantwortlich für die südliche Gruppe
oder zumindest in den Monaten Mai bis
Juli das heißt verantwortlich für die
Operation insbesondere an der Person
Front und wenn sie anschauen
nördlich des Nepper also diese Gruppe
die im Moment da ziemlich stark
zusammengeschoben wird von den Ukrainern
und große logistische Probleme hat da
muss ich sagen sehen wir eigentlich
nicht entscheidend andere
operationsführungen oder entscheidend
andere Maßnahmen dass diejenigen die wir
vorhin gesehen haben also insofern würde
ich sagen so Rohr wir gehen ein weiterer
brutaler Armeegeneral aber ich glaube
nicht dass das den Kriegsverlauf
wesentlich beeinflussen wird jetzt noch
ein anderer Aspekt der belarussische
Staatschef Lukaschenko hat ja gesagt er
stellt jetzt mit Russland gemeinsam
Truppen auf wie ist das zu bewerten
ja ich sage mal Luca Schenker ist ein
bisschen schlauer als man normalerweise
meint auch so als als er in den Medien
erscheinte erscheint ja immer so ein
bisschen Teppich und und so ein bisschen
dümlich aber ich glaube schon dass dass
er sehr genau weiß wie es um die
Stabilität seines Regimes bestellt ist
es gibt auch eine starke Dialog
russische
Opposition im Ausland also es kann
zweierlei heißen einerseits könnte es
sein dass er die Reserven die er hat
also so vielleicht 500 Kampfpanzer
schätzt man haltungszustand
Einsatzfähigkeit unbekannt dass er die
Putin zur Verfügung stellt also als
Ersatz für die vielen vielen russischen
Panzer die die Ukrainer entweder
zerstört oder sich angeeignet haben
man spekuliert im Moment wie
wahrscheinlich ist es das Weißrussland
eine zweite Front aufmacht im Norden
also quasi gegen die Ukraine ich halte
das für relativ unwahrscheinlich wenn
Lukaschenko das macht ist dass der
Untergang sowohl seine Armee als auch
seines Regimes ich denke eher er wird es
so machen wie wir es auch im Februar und
März schon gesehen haben also wird die
Russen vielleicht seine Eisenbahn nutzen
lassen seine Infrastrukturen ich glaube
aber nicht dass er aktiv wirklich in den
Krieg eingreifen wird der Titel unseres
Streams ist schutzlos gegen Putins
Luftangriffe ist die Ukrainer schutzlos
und nein schutzlos ist sie nicht die
Ukraine hat einfach ein Problem sie ist
nun mal ein sehr großes Land das heißt
an eine sehr sehr große geographische
Fläche die man schützen muss und pro
luftabwehrsystemen können sie halt nur
ein bestimmtes Ziel schützen und nun ist
es so dass der Raum Kiew zum Beispiel im
Februar März eigentlich recht gute Luft
Abwehr hatte weil die ukrainische
Luftabwehr sich damals auf diesen Raum
konzentriert hat nun ist es aber so dass
die gefechtsführung es sich verlagert
hat an die Don was unter die
versandfront und natürlich ist ein Teil
der Luftabwehr dorthin verlegt worden
zum Beispiel um die russische
Kampfführung aus der Luft dort zu
unterbinden das heißt dieses Systeme
fehlen ihnen jetzt in im Raum Kiew wurde
auch in den anderen Städten bzw bei den
Energieinfrastrukturen da sie diese
Systeme nicht aus der Kampfführung
wieder abziehen können wäre es jetzt
sehr sehr wichtig dass der Westen
entsprechend schnell
nachliefert und da sind wir genau bei
dem Problem
das Problem ist eigentlich nicht die
Technologie des Problems dass die
westliche
Rüstungsindustrie die Produktion solcher
Systeme etwas vernachlässigt hat in den
letzten Jahren
das heißt die Technologie ist da aber
nicht die eine große Anzahl von Systemen
die man jetzt kurzfristig hineinschieben
könnte die einzige Ausnahme wäre Israel
mit den eierndom-systemen da müsste
Israel aber sich zunächst einmal klar
antirussisch positionieren was es bisher
noch nicht getan hat die Deutschen haben
bisher ein Iris tslm geliefert
soweit ich sehe gibt es zwei nass Ems
also norwegische Abwehrsysteme eine
Möglichkeit wären auch Patriot Systeme
der USA die brauchen allerdings etwas
länger in der Schulung trotzdem muss man
sagen Luftabwehr wenn das die Zukunft
hier der der russischen Operation ist
wird sicher ein sehr wichtiges Thema und
man sollte da so schnell wie möglich
aufbauen
und Deutschland will ja hochmoderne
luftverteidigungssysteme liefern das ist
ja schon versprochen am Thomas gonzia
und Claudia Weiler haben da paar
Informationen für uns zusammengetragen
dieses Gerät soll ganze ukrainische
Städte und Regionen vor Angriffen
schützen sein Name Iris t SLM ein
Luftabwehrsystem modern bodengestützt
ein deutsches Produkt es ermöglicht über
einer Stadt eine Art Flugverbotszone
einzurichten bis zu 40 km weit wert das
System Attacken ab Attacken mit
Flugzeugen Drohnen oder Kurzstrecken
Raketen vier Stück davon hatte
Verteidigungsministerin Lambrecht bei
ihrem Besuch in der Ukraine versprochen
vor gut einer Woche ein System komme in
den folgenden Tagen bekräftigte sie
heute drei weitere erst nächstes Jahr
die Finanzierung je 140 Millionen sei
gesichert nicht genug gesichert scheinen
aktuell ukrainische Städte
braucht es mehr Unterstützung bei der
Luftverteidigung und ist das vielleicht
aktuell so wie sich die Lage entwickelt
jetzt wichtiger als die Lieferung von
Kampfpanzern die in Deutschland ja so
heißt diskutiert wird
die Frage ist nicht ist wichtiger als B
sie brauchen beides und zwar viel davon
das eine betrifft den Schutz der
kritischen Infrastrukturen der
Energieversorgung und der
Zivilbevölkerung also nicht nur der
militärischen sondern vor allem auch der
zivilen Ziele und das ist vor allem
meine Aufgabe der Luftverteidigung der
Krieg wird aber nicht durch
Luftverteidigung gewonnen der Krieg wird
dadurch gewonnen dass die russischen
Truppen aus der Ukraine und das schließt
die Krim ein hinausgeworfen werden das
heißt also dafür brauchen sie offensiv
Mitte mit anderen Worten Panzer die
Frage ist nicht A oder B die Frage ist
vielmehr beides und zwar möglichst
schnell und ich sage das insbesondere an
die Adresse derer die glauben nun müsse
der Krieg möglichst bald oder möglichst
schnell zu Ende gehen dieses Ziel
erreicht man nicht indem man mit
Diktatoren verhandelt sondern indem man
die Diktatoren auffordert ihre
Aggressionen zu beenden und wenn sie das
nicht freiwillig tun sie mit Gewalt
hinauswirft ob das den deutschen
Politikern mittlerweile klar geworden
ist ist mir unbekannt weil ich zum Glück
in der Schweiz sitze aber ich möchte
ehrlich die Frage stellen wie viel tote
ukrainische Zivilisten brauchen sie
eigentlich noch bis sie dieses Prinzip
verstanden haben ich denke das ist eine
Frage die man gerade in Deutschland
vermehrt stellen sollte
die Gegner von
Lieferung kampfpanzerlieferungen sagen
zum Beispiel möglicherweise würde die
Lieferung von Kampfpanzern noch mehr Öl
ins Feuer schütten wie sehen Sie das
ja also diese diesen Herrschaften würde
ich mal einen Kurs nahelegen wie man mit
russischen Entscheidungsträgern zu reden
hat
es ist nicht so dass man in Russland
nicht auf die deutschen hört im
Gegenteil das war übrigens damals schon
in der Sowjetunion so dass das Votum der
deutschen sehr genau beachtet wird in
Russland und dort auch viel zählt nur
müssen sie auch sehen in Russland wird
vor allem eines respektiert nämlich Mut
und Stärke und die russische
Umgangskultur ist nun mal eine andere
als die westliche so wie westliche
Politiker im Moment mit Russland oder
mit Putin reden werden sie schlichtweg
nicht ernst genommen weil Putin dann
immer noch das Gefühl hat das sind
eigentlich völlig verweichlichte
Menschen mit denen kann ich spielen
beziehungsweise da habe ich immer noch
manövrierraum angenommen es würden 200
Leo A4 auf Rollen aus sowohl Deutschland
als auch Spanien ich glaube da würde er
schnell zu anderen Schlussfolgerungen
kommen gegenüber diesem Russland hilft
nur eines nämlich eine Politik der
Stärke und wenn die deutschen Politiker
das nicht einsehen wollen dann werden
sie sich irgendwann der Frage stellen
müssen ob sie nicht gerade durch diese
Politik den Krieg verlängern
ich glaube damit haben sie die Frage von
Marco auf Youtube schon
beantwortet der gefragt hat ob sie
glauben dass eine diplomatische Lösung
überhaupt noch möglich ist und geben
vielleicht auch Ebola eine Antwort die
schreibt die Ukraine muss sich für
Friedensverhandlungen öffnen
ja also Menschen die das die das
behaupten stelle ich ja immer das schöne
Zitat von Golda Meyer entgegen die
gesagt hat es ist schwer mit einem
Gegner zu verhandeln der sie töten
möchte und der Ihnen sowohl die
staatliche Existenz als auch das
Lebensrecht abspricht wir sind längst
jenseits der Frage ob
Friedensverhandlungen eingeleitet werden
könnten oder allgemein Verhandlungen die
Frage hätten wir uns im Herbst 21
stellen können es gibt nur einen Weg
diesen Krieg zu beenden nämlich dass die
russischen Truppen die Ukraine verlassen
und da würde ich Ihnen jetzt gerne die
Frage stellen was muss dafür passieren
naja es gibt mehrere Möglichkeiten die
offensichtlichste Möglichkeit ist die
Anwendung von Gewalt das heißt also dass
die russischen Truppen militärisch
zurückgedrängt werden was sich
möglicherweise bis September 23 wenn es
sehr gut läuft für die Ukraine
vielleicht nur bis Mai 23 hinziehen wird
aber natürlich mit weiteren
militärischen und zivilen Opfern die
zweite Möglichkeit besteht theoretisch
ist aber im Moment relativ
unwahrscheinlich nämlich ein interner
Regimewechsel in Russland der
tatsächlich demilitarisieren würde ich
sehe zwar schon die Möglichkeit dass es
zu einem regime-wechsel in Russland
kommen wird ich glaube aber nicht dass
der Krieg dann aufhört im Gegenteil ich
glaube er wird dann noch radikaler
werden weil wenn ein regime-wechsel
passiert dann wird die
ultra-nationalistische Schiene an die
Macht kommen die dann überhaupt keine
Hemmungen mehr haben wird
eine dritte Möglichkeit ist dass es zu
einer weiteren Eskalation kommt und im
Rahmen dieser Eskalation der Krieg dann
sehr sehr schnell zu Ende geht also zum
Beispiel das Putin so dumm sein sollte
tatsächlich ein atomaren demonstrator zu
zünden also eine kleine einen kleinen
Sprengkopf sagen wir von einer Kilotonne
vielleicht in der Atmosphäre über dem
Schwarzen Meer weil das würde eine
massive Reaktion sowohl Chinas als auch
der USA provozieren da wäre der Krieg in
wenigen Tagen beendet aber dass das
genau das was was vielen Menschen Angst
macht für wie wahrscheinlich halten Sie
den Einsatz von Atomwaffen angesichts
dieser neuen Entwicklung
ich halte es nach wie vor für sehr
unwahrscheinlich sowohl als
militärischen als auch aus strategischen
Gründen also zunächst mal müssen die
Zuschauer eines verstehen man weiß
ziemlich genau wo die russischen
Sprengköpfe liegen es sind etwa 40
sogenannte strategische Lage die werden
überwacht von einem engen Netzwerk von
infrarot-satelliten und wir haben in den
vergangenen Tagen trotz der ganzen
Drohungen die Putin ausgesprochen hat
keinerlei Veränderungen gesehen in der
nuklearen Bereitschaft Russlands das
heißt bevor er so etwas tun würde würde
man zunächst mal eines sehen nämlich die
Öffnung dieser Lager und die
Zusammenführung der atomaren Sprengköpfe
mit den Trägersystemen das würden sie
innerhalb von Minuten bemerken das heißt
also lange bevor eine solche Waffe
überhaupt abgefeuert werden könnte würde
man es beobachten und würde entsprechend
sofort gegen Maßnahmen einleiten die USA
haben das Putin ja sehr sehr klar
gemacht womit er dann zu rechnen hätte
es macht aber auch für Putin strategisch
keinen Sinn wenn er so dumm sein sollte
eine solche Eskalation wirklich in Kauf
zu nehmen dann ist das nicht nur das
Ende seines Regimes es wird auch das
Ende der Russischen Föderation sein wie
wir sie kennen
und das kann nicht in seinem Ziel sein
also weder als Politiker noch im Sinne
der Sila Wiki insgesamt ja also man
macht ja immer so viel an der Person
Putin fest aber putin ist eigentlich nur
ein Repräsentant für eine Gruppe von
Menschen die eigentlich aus dem
Herrschaftssystem der Sowjetunion
stammen und sich das moderne Russland
angeeignet haben also die sogenannten
Silage davon würde ich sagen ist Plateau
Chef das Schlimmste es gibt auch andere
wie Iwanow zum Beispiel die ähnlich
denken aber
deren Regime ist nur so lange sicher
solange sie den Krieg nicht nuklear
führen also solange sie zu einer eine
Art Containment machen und sagen okay
wir müssen die ultra-nationalisten
irgendwie bedienen wir können aber
gleichzeitig nicht riskieren dass unsere
Regime untergeht und dieses Kalkül das
ist sehr sehr lebendig unter den
silobity und ich glaube das gerade
deswegen nuklearer Einsatz das Letzte
ist was sie erwägen würden es gibt immer
noch genügend Möglichkeiten für diese
Leute konventionell zu eskalieren
insofern würde ich da sagen wir sind im
Westen einfach nicht mehr gewohnt mit
der nuklearen Bedrohung umzugehen aber
ich sage auch immer folgendes die Welt
ist immer nur fünf Minuten von der
nuklearen Auseinandersetzung entfernt
und das einzige was sie davon abhält ist
die totale Zerstörungswirkung deines
nuklearen Krieges das war für die ältere
Generation auch für meine im Kalten
Krieg eigentlich Normalfall also ich
erinnere mich noch sehr genau als Kind
in Westdeutschland war das Teil des
täglichen Lebens diese nuklearwelt wir
haben das heute so ein bisschen
vergessen oder verdrängt und ich denke
es ist gar nicht schlecht dass wir das
jetzt wieder erleben um uns mit dieser
Bedrohungslage zu befassen
auch wenn es teilweise unglaublich
schwer fällt Herr Kolb ich danke Ihnen
ganz herzlich wir werden weiter darüber
reden wir werden das auch weiter
beobachten machen sie es gut tschüss sie
auch
so und normalerweise würden wir jetzt
weiter sprechen mit Agnes Marie Marie
Agnes stracc Zimmermann die Vorsitzende
des Verteidigungsausschusses im
Bundestag so habe ich es ja auch
angekündigt sie ist uns leider abhanden
gekommen ist schon auf dem Weg zu ihrem
nächsten Termin es hat leider nicht
geklappt ich hoffe dann beim nächsten
Mal trotzdem möchte ich mich ganz
herzlich für die Fragen und Kommentare
aus der Community bedanken und ich hoffe
wir sehen uns bald wieder bis dann
tschüss